right so we gonna play video zombie okay
I'm gonna invade your game so you're a
running zombie
running jumping killing actually
terrifying yes can I have like a machine
gun or something
ah no no no oh right okay um you're
gonna be with the weapons that you have
in your inventory because the way it
happens is totally seamless so you just
play your game and every time your night
happens denied counter can invade your
game alright so uh are you ready yeah
ready as I'll ever be he's gonna be this
on me me okay uh before I start killing
you um I'll get to New York so that you
can check how your nitrous oxide works
maybe night hunter and your UV flashing
alright alright so I'm on the top of
that car
use your survivor Center use your spy
versus ICU right so that's me when the
pulse turns bright bright orange
that's me coming now if you want to
scare me away you got to use your UV
flashlight it's on the it's on the left
trigger so you pointed out it burns my
skin it drains my energy and it you know
disables my skills now to win this game
look at the top of the HUD yeah the
icons on the left are hives that you
need to destroy you destroy five hives
you win got you the ten respawns on the
ride are the number of times I need to
kill you to win the match and it doesn't
matter who I kill right all right okay
okay so you're ready yeah I think so
alright let's do it let's go let's go
let's go there you go oh oh did I
mention you should stick together
oh we should have stuck together I'm
sorry oh oh go looking here oh no oh oh
sorry go take a [ __ ] alright use your
survivor sense check where the hives are
and watch your back right I'm sticking
behind you this time I
I'm going well yeah I'm going straight
to the hive our cut is right behind us
no you're -
okay the soil this high first trying to
catch oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god
damn it oh crap oh oh come on you gotta
get a last Roy that's right that's right
you see there you still hit me you know
it's not killing me just yeah I'll kill
you I did it yeah I didn't we can stop
we can take them I want to know why
that's only was hiring $18 are you fine
very good we'll stop I just turned off
your flashlight
how about ah don't leave your friends
alone
okay let's stick together guys shouldn't
leave your friends alone you know
playing as a night hunter my best tactic
is to get you got sky separating you
really need to stay together and watch
each other's back in horror movies they
split up and they succeed in doing so
okay and then they die alright gotta get
out of here
Oh somebody loves my ass room how you
doing
worthy worthy huh no yes Thank You V oh
mercy he's hiding into the tada that's
here how you doing Oh get out of here
yes what you were your you want to do
waiting the whole match oh it's just um
talk to you vu well you know it doesn't
kill me
drains my energy so it disabled my jobs
and I it's really hard for me to move
but it doesn't really kill me you still
have to hit me mark along following
email okay me yeah there we go I see you
guys I know I see a little guy oh yeah
that's right Oh does other UV stuff oh
crap yeah now uh don't link tonight one
oh crap how was that move how's it that
oh that was a really bad move get away
get away okay
Roy yeah my uh-huh
ready or not here I come
you can't hide well some food cheese
yeah get a fine g90 sauce was a nineties
night on me later I'll pay off steaks
coming right okay okay okay oh oh that's
a little playing that calls the horn of
the impact head - Amy Rosie where is he
where is he
don't call these my side he's my side
then like it when I can't see it right
right oh crap you saw me oh man get away
go away go away
Oh stupid company I know it takes my
wives zombie has a cell phone
repeat zombie has a cell phone dad you
know it takes is my wife calling me
today Rob help us oh ah victory hey
honey I just won so hearing some good
words for my wife I'm ready to kick your
ass again good stuff so two of you are
sticking together and third one hey rod
one used to leave a like ha he doesn't
like to live apparently
hijack your truck with me mate oh I was
just uh I was trying to squeeze under
that thing look I'll put you back on
we have my back thank God oh yeah that
was younger oh nice Rob's got my back
I'm cool too attack it I know right
thank you yeah well I'll admit it is bad
humor
I'll crap you set up the safe house here
I caught it off
oh is it to sake what are you your
thickness okay right gotcha right so one
of us attacks one of us covered okay
I've only got a hammer
oh my flashlight I really thought you
maybe thought you knew me oh oh you
former thank you
I've got he's over there over there over
on the roof all right there he is
yeah you stay back stay back
I feel carrots yeah I saw you the lights
made it right I'm throwing I can be
revived
not thrown Robbie I'm just surveying the
surroundings following guys yeah yeah
minding its course now watch for
movement oh yeah
no not not yeah That's not me let's try
to kill him he's out there are we going
infinity V by the way
well it uh do you drain it there's an
icon in the top bottom sorry bottom left
corner so when you drain the whole thing
you need to wait for it very doing yeah
yeah oh so they're attempting to rejoin
the team like I got stranded oh thank
you yeah I'm Mel sprinting I'm looking
through my monitor cut myself that
willing so little ice on mobile cheating
okay now slowly approach the EO nests
very slowly
look that's map they're gonna got him
nice so good oh man no no no not yet not
yet me that is the ground pound oh come
on it does drain I'm chilly
but let's take out these things but I'm
basically just get on my flashlights
running out it's okay
okay rule together look he's there but
oh I just nearly
got it
oh man that was bad news I didn't reach
that rooftop come on get away get away
get away get away
all right see that oh I'm gonna break
through it okay that's a bad idea
your lights out yeah all right movie Oh
oh god I'm stuck oh no oh no oh yes I've
only got flares I think that's good
that's still good firing them pretty
much randomly now come on it's like I'm
gonna go gently into the good night why
cruel world I see you yeah I don't later
mommy help me I just realized that
pressing the a button is key yes boy
being in this ah you bastard
yeah yeah and what may hey stay away
from me I was just behind you can we
book to that exact still do this where
I'm basically gonna follow you around
mark I don't think that's a good idea
for sure right the wall doctor who comes
to our right to our right to our right
all right there he is there he is yeah
Oh back off mate well idly I think I
disabled at least one of your
flashlights what I was wrong yeah no
point in oh crap where did you come from
yeah how do I enable my flashlight oh I
just used there oh you chose Larry to
use the d-pad left one more time yeah
there you go
okay let's gather again yeah yeah
he's 12 left somewhere on misery pops
there is I see him oh that's why oh yeah
he went the Basinger no no that's
cheating man no you're right okay well
you don't really care god I would come
when is this close you know anything
goes anything I've ever heard no one
right behind us I see him there he is on
the rooftops get on down the alleyway
okay you guys get going to jail so i
right you are right
yeah yeah he's over there yeah I see him
close
very close
I didn't volunteer look to your screen
again okay that he's that see him okay
he's still a distance from me runs right
by me oh go on a push Go Go Go
we can do it we can do it I wanna beat
ours under the bridge oh oh yeah you
still have to be careful you still have
to look for the other zombies
oh look so you well let me remind you
will bless you concede the 12-page I
love it when we're talking here I'm
right okay
go you go I tried rough my last act I
try